Hace seis años que el capitán bunyamín
dirige el ferry beykos por estas costas
se conoce el bósforo y Estambul a la
perfección
Pese a que esta vía marítima es una de
las más transitadas y difíciles del
mundo bunyamín disfruta tranquilo de su
trabajo
A veces curioseamos si vemos un carguero
muy grande Cuántos metros mide qué
longitud tiene a través del sistema lo
vemos también Hacia dónde va
el bacon es una de las decenas de ferias
que cada día transitan constantemente
entre Asia y Europa los dos continentes
que convergen en Estambul Todo bajo una
de las vistas más famosas del mundo en
las entrañas del barco sin embargo harum
no las puede disfrutar
modo arte que al estar acostumbrado ya
no miro donde estoy si Hemos salido del
bósforo o no me he acostumbrado también
a estas vistas Aunque mi trabajo esté
debajo del agua
más arriba los pasajeros disfrutan de lo
que ven a través de las ventanas
antes los ferries eran la única forma de
ir al otro lado
ahora carreteras puentes túneles y
metros unen las orillas de Estambul los
barcos se han convertido en un
transporte de nostalgia la música lo
recorre
el trayecto se convierte en algo
divertido al mismo tiempo la gente Mira
las vistas mientras escucha música en
directo bebe su té y en 20 minutos han
cruzado el continente por las otras vías
Hay mucho tráfico
en una metrópoli de 16 millones el
bósforo y sus transeúntes de hierro son
un oasis de tranquilidad lejos del ruido
de la ciudad de tráfico y motores dentro
de estas aguas el trayecto se convierte
en un viaje al pasado